Hello! Welcome to a new Project Kampupdate!
This week, it has been very busy at the Kamp.
Now, in this video, we will show you
three improvements we have been working on.
We're going to start building our Level 2house,
continue with our never-ending task of freeing the native trees...
And, we will do a cool upcycling project!
So, there is a lot of stuff to do,
and the first thing is to start building the Level 2 house.
Here we go!
- In previous updates, you saw bringingthis pig trailer to our land.
Then, we saw the state of it,
took out what was not usable anymore and repaired it.
Now, we have a clean structure to work on,
so we are goingto bring the materials and start building!
In order to start the interior of the new Level 2 house,
we have to build a woodenframe.
Just so we have a base easier to build on
wherewe can put the insulation, the electrics and more.
For that, we are using these battens.
They willbe attached to the steel frame of the trailer.
They'll be the transition between the exteriorsteel frame
and the interior wooden frame.
- Here, we have these battens.
We all have tocut them in a little angle.
It's because we put them in here,
in between the steel and therest of the wood.
The water coming from up there can run off.
And, this has the same thickness as thetube,
so we have a nice flat surface to work on!
- Good enough.
We've put these lovely battens in.
We have cut out the doors.
And, the windows...
- Windows.
So, yeah, we have to close all the battens on the back.
Just to be able to foileverything.
Teamwork!
One foiling, other ones--
- Battening.
I don't know if it's gonna hold.
Oh yeah! It seems to fit!
We've put all thebattens in.
Before we can keep on going...
The door, the entrance door, is going here,
so we have to cut.
Like butter!
I got a new antenna!
- So, we just bought the foil,
and now we can put it up with some OSB planks.
The water shouldn't get in.
- We're goingto put it in between this stuff and the wall.
It's waterproof, but it's still breathable.
If water comes in, it can get out, but...
Most of the water cannot get in.
It's an importantlayer for the durability of structure.
- The foil is done!
The next step is to attach these OSB boards.
These boards are made out of compressed leftover wood chips.
We decided to use them, because then the foil is supported.
So, it doesn't break and it stays in place in the long run.
We know it's not the most sustainable material, but it's thin and light.
There areno many more options available in the sawmill...
Now, we are cutting the holeswhere the windows will go.
- Okay, one more...
So, the OSB is in.
The foil's in.
The next thing we want to do is getthe foil
and put this to the outside of the steel as much as possible
Because now, thewater can run along the foil.
If there is a leak, it then will enter somewhere
in betweenthe steel and the wooden frame.
We're going to take it out as much as possible,
andtry to flap it a bit over the steel beam.
So, the first beam of the walls will be straighton the steel.
You can see the ground here.
It's really the bottom of the truck, and it's on the cold steel...
We want to get some oil on it, to make it a bit more durable.
Because, it can be a humidplace in there.
- After oiling these beams, we screw them into the steel frame.
This is the newbase, which the wooden frame is going to sit on.
- That was good.
Okay, now we can start framing.
So, thefirst step is to build the window frames.
My problem is with the heat.
- For a million dollars, would you live--
Robert is interested in a million dollar question.
- For a million dollars, would you want
to survive one year in the Ice Age?
In the Ice Age?
- Yeah, likewith mammoths, and--
That would be cool!
- A T-Rex.
Yeah!
Can I bring my tools with me?
- Yes,you can!
Yeah? Just woodwork over there...
I'm good where I am right now!
I don't need a million dollars!
The two windows are framed out,
soright now we're gonna put them in place.
That's good!
Then, we kepton building the rest of the frame,
but we lost some footage...
So, here's a timelapse of it.
- Is it hot up there?
You can't feel it watching the videos on YouTube, but...
It's 10 o'clock in the morning, and itfeels like 40 degrees already.
But, hey!
I can't say anything.
I'm having fun working!
With Robert behind the camera, and working with me.
- Yes, sir.
We are just positive!
This is our last piece of the framing.
It's starting to be not doable anymore...
I mean, for sure, I don't lookgood,
but you don't look better.
It's shaking!
My hand is fucking shaking!
There,that's better.
Framing finished, Robert-o!
The walls are all done!
So, yeah, we can startwith the with the roof.
- So, we get some shade!
But, I guess we're gonna wait until tomorrow...
We'll keep on doing stuff tomorrow, because it's notdoable.
I'm sweaty.
- The new house is starting to take shape,
but it's too hot to continue today!
So,we will continue building in the next update.
Okay, that was the pig trailer.
Now, we're gonna go tothe fields,
because we will clear some mimosas over there.
Just to make the roads nice and tidy,
so, we'll moveon to the next chapter!
Right here is the main road, that crosses our land.
We need to clean it, because if there is a wildfire,
we will need to use this road to escape.
And, having all these mimosasaround means a potential risk.
They could catch fire, and make it dangerous to drive away.
Or, evenworse, they could burn and fall, blocking the road.
Today, we will be working on this side ofthe road.
Here, you basically find mimosa trees and some oaks.
As we are still in thefire season here in Portugal,
we can only use power tools in the early morning.
So, it's time to start.
- Are you ready to 'bramble'?
These last three of this patch a bit big.
We are a bit worried about the ruin.
So, let's try to see if we can carry on,
without breaking the whole Community Center.
Somehow, even though we just filleted
abunch of trees, this pomegranate made it.
- It's always annoying to work with brambles,
which are spikyand entangled.
But, not everything is bad!
- We've reached a bit of a precarious situationhere.
We have a ton of these dead and burnt trees
that are sort of interwoven together,especially at their crowns.
And, it makes it very hard to
pull everything down and clear it out.
So, our plan of action for this will be to send Màtè in,
because I don't want to chainsaw and getcovered by ants.
We will try to cut as many of these at the bottom,
and hopefully the weight ofall these trees will come tumbling down.
Or, we'll have to pull them out ourselves.
But, hopefully,this should be an easy way to deal with this.
- We're almost finished guys!
How do you feel?
- Just aboutas excited as you sound.
Fresh!
- What's the problem?
My hands are vibrating fromthe chainsaw.
I feel like shaking!
But, it's done.
So, no more chainsaw for a while at least.
So, now that we cleared this whole area,
it's veryimportant that we can maintain it.
To maintain it, we do it mostly with the brush cutter.
So, we'regonna make this brush cutter proof.
and remove all the brambles.
Also, the higher stems: we'regonna cut them down,
so we can access it more easily.
- But, before that, let me introduce youto Debbie.
Hey! My name is Debbie!
I'm from the Netherlands, but I'm currently living and traveling
with my love Wouter, our sun Siep and our dog Otis.
I know right!
That escalated quickly.
I'm a yoga teacher and massage therapist.
With a big passion for humans and their crazy
monkey minds, music and growing my own food.
I came to Project Kamp to learn more aboutliving in a community.
Sharing resources and getting inspired by like-minded people.
Forthe future, I hope to find a beautiful
piece of land in the north of Spain.
Where we canbring people together...
And, hopefully, to have a positive influence in a world
that sometimesfeels so fast and stressful for so many people.
- What do you got there?
A big barbed wire!
B.B.W.
- As you can see, the gloves that
you saw us repairing some timeago...
They're holding up quite well.
- This is what we're talkingabout!
A lot of barbed wire.
- That's not our tractor...
It's Antonio, our neighbor.
He came to grab some wood that we just chopped.
Because, we don't really need it all,
so we always offer it.
- And then, he's gonna use it for fire in the winter?
Yes!
- That's amazing!
So, it's done.
Antonio now has a lot ofwood.
- Perfect!
We still have some thin branches laying around, but we called Bruno.
He has a wood chipper.
So, we chop all the wood
and spread it around the base of thecut mimosas.
They'll struggle to sprout again.
Now, this space looks way bigger!
And, more safe, in case of a fire.
This side is done, but the other side still needssome work.
And, it's the one with more variety of native trees.
But, we'll continue this work later!
All right!
So, that was the mimosa clearing.
The next part of the video is actually going to be
aboutthese chairs that I'm sitting in.
They have something to do with that blue tent overthere.
But, Kevin can tell you more about this!
- So, we have this collection of broken down chairs.
Just laying around by the pizza oven...
I thinkthey would need a bit of love.
Since we have some tarp left and they are good for outdoor...
Ithink we can fix the chairs with the tarp.
Let's see!
The first step is to remove the old fabric.
We will tryto keep it and use it as a mold for the new seats.
The blue top I'm using is the leftoverfor fixing the white tent,
that you saw inthe previous update.
So, we cut the fabric up.
Now, we need to trace it on the tarp and cut it up.
The tarp is quite strong, it requires several pass to cut it,
but this also will last very long!
The first two are quite simple!
They're just arectangular shape.
The third one is a bit tricky.
This hole will be needed to fold
the top around the metal frame.
Sewing time!
Let's see if we can manage withthis big tarp
without breaking any needles.
For the first two chairs, I only need to sew theend.
To make a sleeve for the metalrod
that will attach to the frame.
One is done!
The second chair is exactly the same process.
That's too loose...
The third chair is different.
The top willattach to the frame using some Velcro.
You can also see that I reinforced
the hole with some extra tarp.
Finally, I managed to put itin.
As a last thing, I'm gonna put some bolts
to make sure the top stays in place.
Okay...
Now, we have some new chairs!
And, wehave reused some leftover material
from the white tent renovation.
We saved this three verycomfortable chairs
from ending up in the junkyard.
- Okay Kevin! Thank you very much!
They are verycomfy chairs, but we have no much time to sit in this
Because, we're moving on to the next video!
Next week, we are going talk about the challenges.
So, if you want to ask any questions,
put them in thecomments.
And, if you like these videos, support us on Patreon
and you can see them one week ahead!
If not, we'll see you next week on the same channel.
Ciao!